yeah hello and welcome to the splits
game and this video dynamic pulse okay
is he going to play he is going to play
early morning game
it's not that early I just totally slept
in slept in overslept whatever too long
so let's see what we get him taking a
bit of time no no Kay not so much maybe
he's lagging a bit I thinking maybe
lagging ass like a sniper
anyway we got them modern main line off
the petrov i'm playing the system
there's also the short castles system
that karana played once in the World
Championship match in game 11 I think it
was we should be five that is rare here
the main reason is that I have not
cancelled yet so I can still castle
short and I'm not unhappy about this
development cycle f5 here probably yeah
nothing wrong with that I think hmm
it just takes it how do i recapture
they're both both recaptures have some
points the queen is somewhat active one
is six no but I think I rather want to
cover cover cover d5 okay yeah what to
do here I'm going to do this it's a bit
unconventional but I think the knight
can be quite used for him for attacking
purposes let's see I'm I can always just
take on default I'm fine and if he
retreats it I think 95 to c4 I could be
an idea I can draw here I don't keep
forgetting that
so I'm quite happy here he's attacking
the pawn and looking at 86 mm okay we're
probably just before
okay is there a threat not really I can
go away for okay no if I if I guess
now let's see I can I'm close to getting
b3n what kind of move these kind of
moves I don't like to see him totally
did not see that hmm
okay I still wonder if b3 is something
that I could you
yeah I'm not in terrible shape anyway I
can simply take but I wonder if b3 is
something on yeah let's do it
I think you should probably just retreat
now yeah yeah why did i do b3
you know I mean it's not terrible but I
could have just taken only five and I'm
just fine mm-hmm okay
head silly I'm just a pawn down that was
a completely terrible decision known for
no reason really yeah it's awful really
very badly played mmm I didn't I forgot
that he can take a phone or I always
looked rather and just take a form and
if he would if he takes e5 he will also
take a form
yeah he's seeing one movers shouldn't
blunder more one movers and that's a
very silly game you know that's actually
yeah it's it's a it's a winning ending
for white but he's giving me this crown
for no particular reason
the a porn is just immensely strong this
is why I think it's it's probably
winning hmm what could go to b3 anyway
hmm okay I can definitely not take but
on the 4th and he will go before a for
next maybe here
yeah that's the thing this one maybe he
can go see five different rhogam I'm
playing this really badly and he keeps
making mistake so it's kind of kind of
awful c5 was a lot stronger of course
no it's it's still still bad it's still
a very bad position
thank you five King e6 I'm struggling
maybe can even just take a seven and
push the a pawn that's why you're not
working but still
when I'm catching up a little bit on the
clock at least that's not too bad
okay bit of a weird weird position of
the rook so let's go here yeah but it
wasn't all that all that important how
do I get get get get down probably on
this way you need to give [ __ ] checks
from the back and get the play against
the b-pawn my light now is centralized
that was very important so that it can
help in defending it was just not good
well positions perform it's not totally
obvious how is winning that is not
really great I think
okay I can go here he just has this end
the rook is covering this it's very
lucky for white
okay so he has done this okay King c5
would be nice hey it's okay it's not
happening
your position it's still probably just
lost or is it I don't know not probably
not
I know I shouldn't lose really and so
and just go in front of the pawn it's
the simplest and I have no way to win
this right that's very it's a bit cheeky
it's a bit cheeky this idea trying to
win this position now anyway it's raw
it's fine I mean it was completely lost
okay so we have the draw on the board
and I was in a very very bad game
actually and totally unnecessary I have
a an absolutely fine position here like
this is definitely okay for black yeah
I've got all those got to space gain as
in near the engine likes Bishop g5 in
this position hmm all right no it was
not something I paid attention to Bishop
g5 maybe then my move order was wrong
that's possible because in general it's
very helpful to have this end so the
engine wants to take and then cast on
and then then go for this okay I mean I
must be fine it I have very good counter
play here on the queenside just normal
not normal it's it's an interesting
position with the chances for both sides
so this might be not that great yeah
Bishop g5 but I don't quite understand
what the issue is because maybe this
year this is just a double check Wow
okay here to be 5n g7 I see him I see
him
so that means I have to do something
else then the engine suggests this but
this is looking that looks a bit ugly
yeah well it's definitely better for
item 2 to some extent and probably not a
small extent so I played it wrong I
played this too quickly him it was a
premature pawn push okay this wave
nothing much is going on I think I'm
just fine before it's good yeah but this
is this is okay I believe before C for a
for I mean no I'm not very surprised
that the engine gives me already a
sizable advantage and this doesn't work
due to look a to e8 and then Queen e6
hmm well that is simple that's really
simple I knew it was a bad game but it
was such a simple a simple win okay
great chess yeah b3 is not only giving
black and white an advantage but also
not winning yeah great yeah and I mean
it's so silly
yeah and now here if he just plays in
not a query I mean Queen c2 is a huge
advantage okay but if you just move the
King I'm just two points down for
nothing I can still not take here
because he's six hangs him and now well
yeah white is winning but I'm still kind
of playing no and I think it was winning
for quite a long time still yeah here I
didn't quite get why he didn't push the
pawns
I was thinking c5 actually but b5 seems
to be even stronger yeah dominating the
night yet the taking is wrong but yeah
it's still so bad so yeah this one a 57
yeah I'm just hanging on
and now the end yet this was a strange
move somehow rooty form but it's still
it's so bad I mean it's still a bad
position
yeah whatever yeah you just continue
yeah man now I have some hopes that
could be a draw that could be in wrong
with this king cut off and I think it's
very likely a draw
no way and now I know I'm lost no I'm
lost after c5 probably cause I'm opening
up the six ring would be five was a draw
yeah I'm back and forth yeah that's a
very clean draw actually we cannot do
this and here I'm just going back whoops
and then now I'm threatening this see if
I'm threatening to win the poem
basically and we came no it's still lost
no no it's not lost okay so a6 was
winning yeah yeah I cannot win the pawn
and he gets to a7 it wasn't it was a
really terrible game from start to
finish
yeah no no it's really a draw and
there's nothing nothing to to to to to
wrong here I think in the draw while I
was a bad one need to improve on the
next game thanks for watching